today we're going to talk about excuse
me
okay just one second okay good we're
going to talk about mucus in the back of
your throat I'm sorry I just I just had
to do that
so I've done a video on this topic about
six months ago but I didn't cover all
the underlying causes to this problem
and then understand a little bit more
about it and then also have remedies
that don't end up creating bigger
problems unfortunately when you treat
mucus problems medically uh comes with a
package it comes with side effects
especially if you use antibiotics when
you really have a viral infection
because it's not going to do anything
except you know make your immune system
very very weak
um a good portion of our immune system
actually has to do with our friendly
microbes that are living all around us
outside and inside and as soon as you
start killing those guys off
you have a weakened immune system and
then you get this overgrowth of other
problems so when we're dealing with
mucus in the upper respiratory tract
um you have to realize that any time you
kill off bacteria
you then get an overgrowth of fungus or
candida or Yeast because the bacteria
keep in check all the different fungal
type microorganisms and this is why
people develop candida and throughout
their body and their mouth and the
private parts and also that relates to
the sinuses after an antibiotic here you
are dealing with the bacterial infection
now you're dealing with a fungal
infection right and then you take
stronger medications and then you get
this resistance
to this treatment and now you have even
a stronger microbe so it puts you in a
really bad place so an ideal solution is
a solution that doesn't give you a
bigger problem after you're done trying
to solve it all right so let's just Dive
Right In and talk about all the
potential causes starting with the one
that I talked about in the other video
uh gerd okay gerd is a situation where
you have
um some really severe acid reflux
because the valve on the top of the
stomach is not closing so acid kind of
goes up into the esophagus it can go all
up into the throat and it can irritate
the structures of the throat and create
this inflammation and mucus and a lot of
people have that problem and don't
really connect the dots okay and of
course if they do connect the dots
they're put on an antacid or some drug
that shuts down the acid which usually
just keeps the problem there longer
because the actual underlying cause to
gerd usually is a deficiency of acid you
don't have enough acid or the acid is
not strong enough so anything treatment
wise to weaken that or make this worse
or alkalize your stomach
tends to cause you to go from bad to
worse if you have this problem I do want
you to watch a complete video on acid
reflux and gerd so I will put that down
below but the whole point is this if you
attack the right problem
you get rid of the problem and the
symptoms so one quick way to know if
your gerd or acid reflux whatever is
causing this mucus is simply not to
necessarily spend a lot of money on a
scope you could do that to kind of go
down and scope and see what's going on
and do a very expensive valuation but
what about just taking a very
inexpensive remedy like apple cider
vinegar two tablespoons in some water
and you just start drinking that a few
times a day before the meals and see if
your symptoms go away and then you
pretty much know that was it you can
also take something called betame
hydrochloride which is another good
remedy it's an acidifier it'll help
build up the hydrochloric acid in your
stomach and you would just take like
five before a meal and you might want to
go up each day to like one more one more
because some people need like a good
amount they might need like seven eight
nine ten before a meal before they see
changes but then they're feeling much
much better another indication to know
that if you might have this gerd
connection to your mucus is that you
also have gas
indigestion bloating when you eat next
potential cause is this post nasal drip
situation
and that's creating mucus and it's just
coming from on the back of the sinuses
and it's leaking down into the throat
causing you to cough up mucus this could
be coming from a bacterial infection a
viral infection a fungal infection which
also includes yeast and candida
it can also be coming from biofilms if
you haven't seen my videos on that a
biofilm is a collection a colony of
microbes that band together to help them
survive and usually they produce this
mucoid or mucous layer this slime okay
which happens to be common in the
sinuses and then sometimes even a
calcium shell as in like you would get
tartar in your teeth or even plaquing in
the arteries but the sinuses you just
might have this mucous layer and it's a
biofilm that keeps things resistance
against antibiotics
and other forms of medical treatment
yeah it keeps this constant irritation
in your sinuses where your sinus is
always stuffy you can't sleep at night
because you're snoring and you got this
uh mucus in the back of the throat and a
lot of times if you have more of a
fungal or Yeast or Candida
or biofilms it's just all year long you
have this problem and usually it gets
triggered by taking an antibiotic so if
you've taken an antibiotic let's say
months ago or a few years ago and you
notice wow my sinuses are worse after
that suspect more of a this overgrowth
of either fungus or
biofilms now normally we have biofilms
in the sinuses in the mouth in our
bodies but we shouldn't have a severe
situation where it's an overgrowth of
biofilms and that's what I'm talking
about but think about this these
microbes are just trying to survive
right they need to protect themselves so
anytime you try to kill them with the
wrong thing they will resist that and
become stronger and especially after
antibiotics if this infection is post
nasal drip infection is more bacterial
the mucus will tend to be more yellow or
green if it's viral it'll tend to be
clear or white but that's not 100 it can
cross over you can also have an
infection where you have both
microorganisms living together so
there's a couple solutions that you can
do for this post nasal drip depending on
if it's mild or a major problem okay if
it's a mild problem you can just use
basic salt water or saline solution I
recommend using a sea salt solution and
you you get a Neti Pot which is like
this little nasal rinse and you can put
it up one nostril and let it drain out
the other one you're diluting the salt
there's a lot of videos on like
demonstrating how to do it's really
really easy but it can flush out the
sinuses apparently salt is antimicrobial
especially for bacteria and fungus and
yeast and candida and potentially it
could help viruses too to some degree as
well as help reduce
how the biofilms stick to the inside
layer of your membrane however if it's a
major problem you're going to need
something stronger you'd basically do
half a teaspoon equals 2.5 milliliters
of sea salt into some container you'd
have a cup of water which is eight
ounces or 236 milliliters for those of
you in Europe and my friend Dennis and
so you dissolve the salt in the water
and you use it as a nasal rinse and you
just flush it out that may be enough to
handle this problem okay
but let's say you need something
stronger okay this next combination is
very effective and a lot of doctors
recommend it and use it you're going to
be using a small amount of baby shampoo
yeah baby shampoo
the reason why you're not using regular
shampoo it's just going to be too harsh
and it's going to irritate your mucous
membranes so you want to use something
that is like a no tier very gentle and
something that has the least amount of
chemicals I'm not going to necessarily
give you any Brands you're going to have
to do the research but all you do is you
take two teaspoons of this baby shampoo
and put it into four cups of water and
then you would use that as a nasal rinse
four times a day and it'll help the
mucus dissolve because it's a detergent
it works great on that and because
you're diluting it it's not going to
irritate the inside mucous membranes if
you also wanted to add some of that salt
water you can just do that too and now
you have this pretty effective remedy
there's other things you can do if the
mucus is being generated in the throat
or maybe lower in the sinuses back up um
behind the sinuses way back there or or
even in the larynx
or just the back of the throat that
could happen too or you can have an
infection in your tonsils so let's say
it's back there what do you do I
recommend
povidone eye dag right you can get at
the drugstore okay and you dilute it you
want to get that one that says 10 on the
bottle that's really one percent
absorption okay and you want to dilute
it by 50 with water so you just take
basically a half of an ounce of this
povidone iodine and you mix another half
ounce of water okay so what you do is
you take a Q-tip dip it into this
solution and rub it around the inside of
each nostril iodine is a very potent
antimicrobial and it's going to be
diluted enough where it's not going to
irritate your mucous membranes but now
we add the iodine that's the acid in the
cake and that actually will directly
kill off things in your sinuses then
what you do is you gargle with the rest
to get this material in the back of the
throats then you gargle it for like 30
seconds and then you spit it out okay
and you do that twice a day with a 12
hour time frame between when you gargle
it so now we expose the back of the
throat to this public down iodine which
is a very powerful antimicrobial so that
way we can topically put something to
start to break up this mucus now of
course if this problem is an allergy
environmentally the best thing to do is
to avoid certain parts of your
environment and do fasting prolonged
fasting improves the immune system and
also it actually can help even get rid
of allergies so that's one thing and
then as far as food allergies the most
common food allergy involves Dairy so I
would just simply cut out Dairy and
you're going to find many times that
mucus will go away
now one more point about
the mucus and where it's generated okay
so if it's in sinuses or if it's in the
throat or it's coming from the stomach
coming up that's the most important
thing to figure out
um that's the whole point of this video
is to really isolate and dig down where
the problem is coming from okay now I'm
going to give you another thing to do
that I didn't practice that seems to
work good and I've done a video on this
relating to sore throats but you can
apply this
to this problem too so if the problem is
stemming from the back of your throat
okay
what you can do is a kind of a pressure
point acupressure Point thing where
you're pressing on the back of
your neck now you can't press in the
back of your neck you have to have
someone do it to you but I did a video
on it and you basically have someone
take their two fingers right here and
press
in the vertebra in the back part and
then what you do is you kind of isolate
where that irritation is or where that
mucus is coming from it could be like
right here it could be lower it could be
somewhere through here and then what you
do is you draw a circle around to the
back part of your neck now if you think
this is weird I understand but it really
works you have to try it okay once you
isolated the exact opposite point in the
back of your neck you have someone press
into that point and the way that you
know that you found the right points
because sometimes it's hard is it'll be
very very sore so have the person kind
of go up a little bit higher in the neck
or a little bit lower until they find
the exact point where it's really tender
and then you have them apply that
pressure for a period of two minutes now
the fingers we might get tired you don't
have to press that hard but you're going
to start feeling things breaking up
where things kind of draining or things
feeling less congested or irritated
I don't know exactly why it works but it
works and I've done it many many times
in fact I would have people fly in from
different places around the country for
this problem and I would work on through
the day within a few days it would
greatly help them if not completely get
rid of it so this is just another thing
to do which is a very ninja technique
and so if you have someone around you
that can do this on you that's great I
have built a device do-it-yourself
device you can get that too I'll put
some videos on how to apply that but
it's a little massage tool that you put
in the back of your neck and you can lay
back and let gravity put pressure in the
back of your neck but you can apply
pressure different points in your spine
to just to help whatever's going on on
this side right here there's some type
of place where you're getting irritation
in your throat whether it is a sore
throat or just a point of where you're
generating mucus because some people
generate a mucus from their larynx okay
and that's her voice box and they get
hoarse so they have all this mucus
generated from that this is a great
technique when I did a video on this I
had so many success stories of people
doing this so you can read them check it
out try it if it works great I mean what
do you have to lose you don't want to do
anything to lower your immune system you
want to enhance the immune system the
immune system is ultimately the thing
that's going to heal you not anything
else not a remedy so all you're doing is
assisting the immune system so garlic is
at the top of the list consuming Morgana
garlic through the day garlic in your
food very potent
anti-everything I'm talking about
antiviral bacterial yeast fungus mold
biofilm garlic it should be at the top
of the list number two no sugar sugar
feeds these microbes especially if you
have fungus yeast or candida okay avoid
all sugar and then there's three
remedies that I always recommend for the
immune system a lot of vitamin D
minimally 20 20 to 30 000 I use every
single day vitamin C make sure you do a
natural version not the synthetic
version and then zinc those three are
the go-to for every single immune
problem I would recommend that
and then lastly I would recommend if you
have coughing let's say you have a small
child that's coughing at night because
of this mucus sometimes you can take
calcium lactate and that will just
suppress the cough it's a good remedy
for coughing that could be mucus related
or not
but coughing through the night
especially for kids or adults take the
calcium if you look up one of the
symptoms of low calcium okay
hypocalcemia that would be laryngeal
spasm so you get muscle spasms
especially in this this area right
through in the throat and that can
irritate and create a coughing sensation
all right I gave you a lot to swallow on
this one no pun intended but the next
video you should watch is the other
video on
uh how to get rid of phlegm and mucus
and I put that video up right here check
it out